the cost of safely disposing of the
topic the toxic chemicals is
approximately five times what the
company paid to purchase it
or maybe we have no error so this first
part reads a little bit weird but i
think it's right let's see the cost of
safely disposing of the toxic chemicals
yeah there's a lot of us there but i
think that's right i mean we could have
said the cost of disposing of and this
safely is just an adverb describing of
how we're disposing we're safely
disposing so this seems reasonable the
cost of safely disposing of the toxic
chemicals it's a little bit a little bit
a lot of wordy it's got the of there but
it doesn't seem wrong the cost of safely
disposing of the toxic chemicals is
approximately so we're talking about the
cost so we have it's a singular subject
and so it makes sense that we would use
is right over here we'd use the singular
verb the cost is approximately
five times what the company paid to
purchase
it
now this it is a little bit fishy
what is this it
referring to
is this it referring to the cost
is it referring to the cost no this the
it i think based on the meaning of the
sentence is the they're referring to the
chemicals the the the company paid to
purchase the chemicals so this right
over here should be the chemicals
the
chemicals or if they want to use a
pronoun this is a this is a plural noun
right over here the chemicals you would
use to purchase them
you would use to purchase them you
wouldn't you wouldn't use it right over
here this is this this what what did
they purchase they purchased the toxic
they they purchased the toxic chemicals
so it's plural so you would either say
to purchase the chemicals or to purchase
them so let's read it the way let's
let's just read it with let's read it
with the
them
the cost of safely disposing of the
toxic chemicals is approximately five
times what the company paid to purchase
them yeah that makes a little bit more
sense or if you want to be very clear
you could just write the chemicals there
the cost of safely disposing of the
toxic chemicals is approximately five
times what the company paid to purchase
the chemicals yeah that makes it at
least in my mind that's how i would have
written it made it making it very clear